manifestation devant le siège de la
police départementale du val-de-marne
qui se déroulent dans le calme
un calme en apparence seulement puisque
la colère est réelle au sein des membres
des forces de l'ordre profession qui
souffre depuis de nombreuses années de
conditions de travail difficiles mais ce
qui a mis le feu aux poudres d'après de
nombreux policiers ici et bien ce sont
les propos est d'emmanuel macron
diffusée sur brut
vendredi dernier au sujet des contrôles
au faciès et des violences policières
des propos qui ont choqué plus d'un pour
cent des forces de l'ordre nous ce qu'on
attend du président de la république
c'est d'abord de la reconnaissance est
ce qu on attend d'ailleurs de la part de
la plupart des élus de la république
c'est de la reconnaissance mais c'est
aussi des actes quand par exemple on
demande le floutage systématique pour
les policiers lorsque l'on demande new
alliance police nationale
qu'il y ait des sanctions qui soit ferme
à l'encontre des violences contre mes
collègues à l'encontre des gens qui
commettent des violences contre mes
collègues c'est ça aujourd'hui qu'on
demande mais aujourd'hui ces actes qui
viennent pas ils viennent pas et en plus
lorsque le président s'exprime c'est
pour clairement
émettre une défiance vis-à-vis des
fonctionnaires de police et ça c'est
juste intolérables on a des numéros
verts pour tous depuis deux trois ans et
c'est bizarre c'est presque le même
numéro vert à chaque fois ça va être une
plateforme mutualisée et là bas sur la
violence policière
on a déjà en algérie accès ali jes une
plateforme internet on a beaucoup de
choses la police s'est c'est le corps de
l'administration qui est le plus
contrôlé le plus sanctionné
certainement quand il le faut et à juste
titre mais je crois qu'au niveau mondial
on est pas on n'a pas d'équivalent d'une
police qui fait son travail de manière
aussi républicaine et l'annoncé d'un
beauvau de la sécurité a été accueillie
ici avec beaucoup de scepticisme
alliance et synergie deux des plus gros
syndicats de police ont d'ailleurs
d'ores et déjà fait savoir qu'ils ne
participeront pas à ce grenelle de la
police ce qu'attendent les manifestants
et si les forces de l'ordre ce sont des
engagements fermes plus que de belles
paroles de la part du président de la
république